[Musique]
sans livrer de la cuisine en chansons ce
sera terminé ça ça ce move dernier
n'ayant qui chante avec vous les
cuisiniers des madame qui travaille dans
une cuisine un peu partout dans lé
québec
et puis lolo qu'est ce qu'on fait on
voir chanter dans les résidences à nous
avant les fêtes ont affecté 8 se ranger
le ricciardo du haut de ses 82 ans est
toujours très active dans la communauté
cette religieuse hors norme venus des
lycées liées à l'âge de 18 ans a
consacré sa vie à rendre la cuisine
accessible
[Musique]
la terre un premier test un panier de
vie et tout ce qui pousse j'ai toussé
l'utiliser tout continue la vie et ça
c'est un moment mon plan principal puits
aujourd'hui tu vois l'évolution dans la
cuisine dans la créativité et c'est
formidable et je me suis dit est-ce que
j'ai été et complices de cette affaire
entre votre arrivée en 1955 et la
télévision
il y a quand même vu une jeune femme qui
arrive ici et qui décide de faire une
carrière en cuisine c'était réfléchi ou
marie-gérin-lajoie c'est une femme
québécoise qui a fondé la communauté des
soeurs notre dame du bon conseil de
montréal
cette femme elle avait le souci qu'elle
est ça mange bien et là j'ai compris
comment l'alimentation est importante
alors j'étais stimuler à l'orage effet
l'institut familial et social sous
boulevard saint joseph
je recevais les évêques et tout ça sur
boulevard st-joseph et ce faisant la
cuisine pour 300 personnes et j'allais
au marché chez les italiens pour avoir
des herbes inconnu pour pouvoir les
faire connaître
mais moi j'avais le souci d'aller
toujours évolué tout le temps et sous de
l'alimentation a toujours la possibilité
d'aller plus loin
quand vous êtes arrivé on connaissait
pas biais les produits on cuisinait
beaucoup dans les maisons aujourd'hui ce
que j'avais l'impression qu'on a évolué
ou qu'on a perdu un peu diplôme en
chemin aujourd'hui les gens sont dans la
vitesse la vie après un fulgurant et hop
le temps de cuisiner ils vont l'acheter
tout plein et arrive à 5 rue vont les
chercher sopi et ressent l'effet de
semaine quand les parents sont à la
maison qu'elle fasse cuisine et les
enfants les impliquer et qu'ils fassent
une mise en place pour la semaine
s'ils savaient comment ça leur coûte
moins cher parce que tout travail qui
était fait pour préparer les play-offs
que tu paies le problème ils ont enlevé
tout s'écroula dans les écoles moi j'ai
enseigné dans les écoles départ à des
jeunes comme la forêt de l'espoir
on leur donne un cours de base aux
enfants et lola après un savon à l'école
à l'institut calixa-lavallée sans moyens
mais il faut qu'on donne la base il faut
que les enfants retrouvent la vitalité
de la recherche et de l'implication de
bien se nourrir chez soi mais vous avez
berchem s'arrange elle éprouve toujours
autant de bonheur
entrez dans les classes de l'institut de
tourisme et d'hôtellerie du québec où
elle a été enseignante et chercheuse
pendant 16 heures alors là c'est mort
les pépins pour faire la gelée mais pas
dans la vie si on regarde c'est ce
parcours là de la société québécoise
vous arrivez à quelles conclusions
aujourd'hui sont très sélectifs et puis
alors un cuisinier ou un chef il faut
qu'il soit à la hauteur
fouquet une formation adéquate il faut
qu'ils sachent qu est-ce qui fait parce
qu'il ya 2001 un nouveau produit quand
j'arrivais poivrons bien mais pas sans
le sou rabot bissau des dépôts en europe
c'est quoi et puis il y avait des
coyotes et du palais d'al temps les
croissants au déjeuner on connaissait
pas ça on recueille là vous étiez pas au
monde personne bon alors qu'est-ce qui
est totale au toit on se connaît
si vieira mais dire que pendant toutes
ces années j'ai essayé de tout mon coeur
de toute ma générosité et tout mon
implication
je ne sais pas comment j'ai fait je veux
te le dire c'est quasiment un miracle
mais c'était pour aider la société à se
garder en santé ça a été mon souci
premier
et j'ai toujours gardé sens je vois
qu'il ya beaucoup d' amener dame aux
yeux et me ce que vous faites et dites
vous que la cuisine c'est le plus beau
métier au monde
est ce que vous vous êtes fait plaisir
dans votre vie ou es ce que vous avez
toujours fait plaisir aux autres
sur ce truc drôle de question pour une
sortie difficile à répondre j'ai essayé
de faire plaisir à tous et chacun
vous oubliez peut-être mais j'avais
cette vocation de deux de partager des
données voir les gens heureux les côtés
merci s'arrangeait des mots moi c'est
grâce à ma mère qu'aujourd'hui ce
capable de cuisiner ou est-ce qu'on vous
l'avez connu sur j'aime
dans les paroles par les parrains corses
avaient des goûts
à 10 h 10
malade dans l'âme ici à l'école le jeune
eddy suis ici parce que ma mère parlait
de son âge elle mais ça fait chaud au
coeur
sans thil qui a une petite racine qui
restait que si un jour je vais partir il
ya toujours quelque chose par les écrits
par tous qui restent et sa cdc de lacq
c'est ça la consolation pour moi
[Musique]